I'm talking to mrs.
Vera holliday who as vera lawson worked
in the doormen long offices during the
building of the rich do you remember
getting the job there. Yes i certainly do
remember when the college rang and
said that they wanted me to go on
a special. Position in sydney one of the
best positions in sydney at the time and
could i be free straightaway.
And as i gave myself for
a further three weeks i said well i think
you'll have to wait three weeks. And so
i'm very fortunate i decided to wait three
weeks. And when i joined dawn in company
in the chief industrial office which was
one of two offices twin offices the pay
office was attached to this office and i
worked in both of them. Mostly in the
chief industrial office with mr article
vincent who was the chief officer there but
then on thursday and friday. I helped
mr alright he was the paymaster. With
a pay sheet and on friday with
the page making up the page etc.
. There were some times when i would call
along to actually pay the men and that
was quite an experience. Well and that's
what really happened in the pay office but
in the chief industrial officers office
. Every week he prepared the rise and
fall of wages which were just as
made. Between the hourly rate
which was paid to the men between
doormen long and the public
works department. Mr.
Vinson. Worked at the rates and i actually
did the calculations to each week and.
The accountant from public
works department of mr.
Armstrong who would come
down every occasion perhaps
a fortnight or fortnightly if it was very
cold because we always had very beautiful
coal fires in the winter and in the summer
time of course the office was very cool
. It was one of the older buildings down
the doors point and in the summer time
he'd come down because it was cool but he
did it work very well indeed for public
works department. Well then i also kept
the wages records for the men both
on the site in sydney and those of
my review and that was used. If the
in for taxation purpose it and also in
worker's compensation when there was any
accident on the bridge or or down at the
side. The compensation forms would be made
out that the cause of the injury in the
sight of the injury and of course we had to
work out the average weekly wage and
then i think paid two thirds of that
compensation the kind drivers and of the
other men. Incidentally. As the kind went
further up on the on the different
angles of the bridge that paid
a greater rate. And the crane drivers would
have perhaps sometime seven lines of
calculations on the way just shoot each
week depend how many hours they worked at
it. Section as they went up. Do you remember
any of the workers compensation claims
do you remember the accident. There were
thirteen accidents on the sydney side and
there were three in the mirror
you cite. I have been tell of
a lot of the very tragic accident or
thirteen fatal accidents and three fatal
accidents and maria stand corrected. There
were many many other accidents of course
but i'm speaking particularly fake it wasn't
one of course who felt the top of the
pile on and and hit it. You went down. I
don't care to remember the result of that
was. It was very very tragic you know
cause the many others. That fell.
When who feel and struck feet first. Of
course he's his boots was boat believe they
sort of came up his legs
a split. There was another who
feel of face down and that was not
at all. Nice to think about so i put those
well in the back of my memory the actual
fact but i do pay tribute to those men who
did lose their lives on the bridge. What
about them. Oh minor accidents do you see
you get any burns to do. Oh yes. The ones
that i'm laughing now. I bet the poor
little rivet boy is that used to catch the
rivets. Of course they have
a very very clever catching rivets in in
tin cans and they had to be very accurate
but of course the unexpected sometimes
happened that ship would come often that
their trousers we will tucked into their
boots every day and again one would go
into their boots and believe me that can
of water that was ready waiting for them
to jump into was always very
welcome to them. You fill out
a few of those compensation for the
years many of them but. It was
a wonderful period really because i was
quite young was twenty april 21st birthday
on the bridge and the main with whom i work
today and they were absolute gentlemen
and they just looked after me as brothers
and i just think they're just wonderful
people. And as the years went on of course
our we were all interested in the bridge
to the granite came and maria and the
pylons grew and my immediate chief was to
be instant when anything was finished or
completed sufficiently that i could be
taken. There he would take me out into the
site. And i remember gain up to the top
of the abutment towers and just before they
were quite complete but their work was
letters were still there and up to the
letters we with and up the letters we went
of course and that was we had our photos
taken later with some of the girls in the
general office but that was very much in
the raw and i was always pleased to go
where there was one time when i'm afraid.
I had to say you know that when the arch
was joined and the big mama drearily
came and he said to me. Come on be
a commando at the top of the arch. And i
just couldn't i would have loved to have
gone but i just couldn't because i've seen.
I had seen too many people too many men
come down from their white faced when
a sudden gust of wind did come. And they
did to hang on for dear life. And i
thought well that could happen to
me and i'd rather be down here as
a said before it hurts when you for. Did
you ever get taken out of the workshops at
all. Oh yes yes several times. I was taken
over there when the central hager was
completed and my chief took me over in the
launch. He said come on that before that
goes up have a look at it and have
a touch of it and so we went out and we saw
the central hangar and it seemed to go
on forever as we were walking it was lying
and of course on the side and it seemed
to go on forever but that was
indeed quite a privilege it was
a privilege to be able to go through the
workshops and see the work that the men
were doing it was such wonderful work and
such exacting work. The rivets. There are
so many many rivets and each one had to
be perfect in this city. And they're all
very very skilled to remember
what the wage bill for
a week was the doorman long in those days
but i thousand pound and you know it's
the. Very big wage bill that was the
sydney site of course there are better.
Hundred fifty men there and actually about
250 down at maria. But the sydney wage
bill averaged about 8000 pounds.
And as the paymaster stated
in my reference that was an enormous wage
bill. How much did you get out of that.
Well the average weekly
wage i think the wage
a man wife and child was about three pounds
three pound. Five and i was fortunate
enough to get four pounds five. At that
particular time my wages went up later.
Here's a do in the invoices didn't you.
Oh i did the invoices from the u.s.
From england. I checked. I'd
all the steel invoices that
came from england. Or were sent to me
and i checked them. Of course with my
theories tables and on the machines etc.
And they were very interesting
interesting indeed as
a matter fete. Because we could see the
port boats coming into the hall from the
other side. You've had workshops and then
of course later on to get the i'd get the
invoices for the steel that
was delivered and it made it
a living thing i knew what was happening i
knew where the steel was going from the
invoices etc and working was something
that was alive. Came alive under my fingers.
Do you remember any social occasions
while you were on the verge of
a social occasion yes well it was almost
as though she occasion weekly because we
used to alternate saturday mornings. As
far as the working was concerned but i
didn't want to stay. However saturday morning
because. After we finished had lunch
at twelve o'clock. Whatever time. Some of
us would always go so here. But of course
. The first big social occasion was when
the archers joined. Really and your
arch was joined the 19th of
august 1930. But mr innes gay was
a dinner dance mistress of ennis gave us
a dinner dance at the winter of hotel. On
the 4th of september 1030. And it was it
was wonderful. Of course that the all
of the officers were invited. And
a lot of the executives for their and
leading river do was there and his
wife and many in
a associated with doormen long. And
remember the foreman rigger who was it
also appears in that picture.
Oh yes. And that was mr.
Harris who's
a little man but he get anywhere because
he was so small you get into all the most
awkward corners and he was very active of
course he was everywhere and he loved to
be known as the human fly. But yes i have
a picture of that occasion. Showing mr.
Mrs. In it on the left hand side
and course mr. Alf marr. Mr.
Innis. Was director of
construction of course mr.
Alf martin was second in charge and on
the other side of the picture was mr.
And mrs.
. Cerar freeman who was and or many
of the others who were in executive
positions there. But it was
a very wonderful night for me because i
worked with them into the pay office and of
course my chief and his offsider.
And i didn't take apart my
boyfriend was in queensland. So they said
well you're out for the night our partner
for the night and i went down there and
they sort of you. We we really are going to
have a night tonight and i danced for
feet of i really did and it was such
a thing of joy. I do. Very pretty
frock and i think of it as one
of these wonderful nights that doesn't often
happen. Do you remember the test match
. You know. Yes this is another
occasion as the as the.
As it was drawing near the end of the bridges
and our association was drawing near
. Just over was you know so to say
that so i remember the test magic.
Indeed i do. It was just after one
of the english australian test match
had been played in england
and of course we had
a very very close victory but there we
worked in complete harmony in the office
there was
a lot of englishmen on the staff. But i
would say almost half and half. There was
a great deal of rivalry of course. And of
course when we won. They said i will take
you on any time we can win that was just
a fluke. So of course. Mistreat us about
lee heard of this and he decided that we
would have
a test match well with the help of the
men in the workshops and the fabricating
workshops. They made as an earner out of
a ten billy type of thing which was about
fifteen or eighteen inches high and they
painted it red and shaped at the same as
an urn and. Put the airship in height on
the front of it and so better hundred of
us went up to fix tree picnic grounds at
lane cove. And we had
a test match there between the australian
pulp mills and the australian australians
. And it was played with much enthusiasm
and the disgust of the englishmen we
again one by one run but we
had a wonderful picnic in
a very very happy day we had in mind of
course the fact that our days together were
were very short and we were really
appreciating the company of our fellow work
people and it was they were soon to be
spread all around the world the bridges to
be built in koala lumpur and and. I think
over in auckland there was an out of one
built and on the other side of the world
we just didn't know where we would each
end up in fact the. The
office manager he called mr.
Crow. He called on me in auckland because
i had been sent over there by the time he
finished to work with an other company
and he was the last of those who were
returning to england. I think dorman
longstaff does anybody you particularly
remember. All of them.
But the immediate ones i
must pay a tribute to my immediate
boss mr ask of instant. He was
a chief industrial officer. There's
not very much said about him he did
a very important. Work
for the win. Job. He he
represented them in court. He went he
interpreted the war in other words he used to
get the interpretations of the award and
work to those and anything at all to do
with the court work. He had
a pretty good work and then of course each
week he used to work out the difference
between. The wage rate that were claim
between the public works department and
doormen long and company and he was
a man who was always on the job and
his advice was very helpful and
his assistant mr cyril kelly. I killed
was wonderful. He was like yet another
big brother to me he used to sit
opposite me. In the angle of
a an l-shaped desk. I had vince on one side
of me to the right and kill in front of
me and he he used to work there
just in front of me and we sort of
chatter away and do our work and. Met fact
he'd go to the pictures with his fiance
over tuesday night and on wednesday
morning. Intermittently through the morning
he'd tell me little fragments of the of
the program and but it didn't mean to say
we weren't doing our work we did our work
all of that. Yes thank you very much. Do
you remember where you were when the
bridge was open. When the bridge was
open i was on top of the bridge you caught
up in the official stand on the eight
stand. We faced the official stand
and near to where the ribbon was.
And of course my chief mr.
Vincent was alongside of me. And we had
a very good view of the precision and we
were able to watch it from approaching
from the right and could see
a long way down the approaches of
the bridge. And at one stage i saw
horsemen approaching hadn't
seen him before but as
a junior year i could see
that horseman and he gave
a magnificent salute to the official
standard. I drew my chief's attention mr.
Winters attention to him and something
made me watch him pass the stand and go
to burst to my left. And approach the
ribbon and then suddenly up went you saw it
and the ribbon was cut and down came mr.
De groot. The captain de groot. I actually
saw that incident. Absolutely. So every
little bit of it because i was so intrigued
with his magnificent horsemanship he
looked as if he was just he in the
water just won that one and it was
a matched. Astonishing thing that happened
right in front of my eyes. What do you
think it is actions and just year astonishment
i didn't know what it was all about
didn't know what it was all about then.
But of course were you ever out of work
after the bridge was finished. I was very
fortunate. No i was never out of work i
had
a skill that was in much demand and i
had two very very good references and i
finished it. The bridge in july which was
on the seventh month and the bridge was
that's frankly six months four months
after the bridge was opened and
i was just about mr. Mr.
Kerr with great regret used to say to the
one whose next man whose turn it was to
go. Well i'm afraid it's your turn and he
knew he used nearly weep but the day i
was called up there is
a real varies and this is the time he said.
I'm afraid i'm going to sack the self
very soon but right we
were talking there my mr.
Vincent my chief and knocked at the
door and came in and he said there was
a firm wanting me on telephone to offer me
a position so that meant that i even
forgot to get a riff a reference from mr.
Vinson. To be i went in such
a hurry to another firm then i eventually
ended up with the atlantic union oil
company in sydney and they transferred me
to their auckland branch and in charge of
their sales tabulation so i
was over there for quite
a ha. So you were never out of work. Did
you finished up at the at the bread so
you've got your bridge workers back to do.
Yes i have my bridge workers badge and
it's all polished up to
here tomorrow. You know.
Do you think that the bridge workers of
those days were better than today. How did
they work. The bridge workers of those
days were absolutely magnificent they did
a good work. They really were they. They
worked sixty minutes for every hour that
they were paid. Even mr.
Lawrence in as the director of construction
were surprised at the quality of their
workmanship and that was proved on november
twenty six 1929 when the record was
broken for steel lifting the total lift
from farve am to five pm was five hundred
seventy eight ten and the world's record
for that type of bridge was three hundred
seventy turned which proved that our
workers were the best in the world. sixty.
You said earlier there are that you
didn't get a reference but you did get
a reference into yet on the 27th of may.
Mr. The commercial manager of the harbour
bridge. Men in charge of
the office he gave me
a reference shall i read it. Part of
it and. Mr certify missive you must be
a lawson has been employed on the harbour
bridge construction office since the one
in their august twenty seven article
commodore operator the carters are
calculations which he has performed
include wages exchange and engineering
calculations in regard to measurement and
quantities invoicing and accountancy the
speed at which you can operate
a machine is in excess of that of any
previous operator within the writers
experience. She has also
carried out this work with
a hundred per cent accuracy. Miss lawson
has also assisted in pay office work
generally and has
undertaken the payment of
a section of the wages from time to time
she is accustomed to handling wages
inquiries and compensation details generally
was lawson has done invaluable work on
the staff including typing and her
services have been greatly appreciated as
a sydney have
a breach of contract is now completed. We
have no further work in view. Miss lawton
we'll be leaving shortly incontinently is
seeking further employment. We cannot too
highly recommend her. And the paymaster's
reference water was given me and he
says in his. As pay mart of the
above mentioned firm dome along. I
desire to place on record my appreciation
of resource and services. Whilst in the
pay office under my direction her duties
were to assist in the calculation of wages
checking occasion making up of same she
was also entirely responsible for the
addition and cashed
a section of all wages and when it is
realised that all hundred and fifty men were
paid weekly in varying rates and an average
weekly wage bill amounted to eight
hundred eight thousand pounds visit the
magnitude of the task and the kennedys as
they will be apparent during my five years
association with mr lawson in the course
of my duties. I have found her to be an
operator of outstanding speed in ability
strictly conscientious of pleasing
personality and question integrity on the
completion of the contract the consequent
severing of my so she ation with these
laws and i give this personal reference
in appreciation of her splendid help w
a will rich paymaster doing long in
company and you said he didn't get
a reference. I thank you very much. Miss
vera lawson as well as mrs era holiday.